[Music]
it looks great expect the conditions to be great I
think it'll be a good atmosphere
for the fans NHL does an amazing
job each year it keeps getting better and
better we're going to try to make most of
it you watch the Winter Classic as a kid
and to be a part of it now and playing in
the game tomorrow is just a dream come
true you look sick get used to going
back on pucks it's a different than what
you're used to it's going to be a little
different tomorrow just can't wait to
get out there it's going to be a lot of
fun
oh that's pretty good love
that super pumped yeah it should be a lot
of fun and uh hopefully we can get a big
win [Music] [Applause] [Music] we got an
opportunity to play in an unbelievable
situation here hey uh Jack eel your line
will start uh Nick and petrol and Logan
and nsy let's go in the first grade man
Welcome to the 2024 discover NHL Winter
Classic in Seattle Washington featuring
The Vegas golden knights and the Seattle
kren fellas welcome to the Winter Classic here
in Seattle let's have a great 2024 and let's
get at it here we go you one on your back wheel
sh SC from just inside the left point with cing
take oneing lead let's go gold we're fine we're
fine there it is the safe long shot bur toide by
Thompson and then drive by BG he scores two
nothing Seattle it's going to be a tough one
keep it going Sor Sor we're going to get one too
many chances to not let's go oh now a steel the
score oh he's robbed the C Q wow going
the cord with the first Winter Classic
shut out Dave hack dos cracking with
a three nothing blanking of the Vegas
golden kns that is one of the coolest
sporting events that I've been a part
of